well welcome welcome to your palms house
[Music]
how does it big that's hard for me
yeah if I put people want to you can
show them a little bit apart you want to
applaud when you really want to sign
from the side
hard okay 15 would possibly reverse I
get tired by I would possibly of us had
apartheid by 5 and we possibly about by
the tired by and we possibly of us at it
quite hard by here's a spot Wow I wasn't
my mom that was really Wow
so impressive yeah that was a mama titty
fart by aka bad friend
it's really good yeah very very
interesting very good job I'm very
impressed with your mother's flow yeah
she's a she's a natural you know she
could see the big natural she does have
those big naturals I'm so funny that
your dad still feels gypped by the bra
that fits her like the we so it's such
an insight into really have his mind
works yeah like it's a cup runneth over
but then her cup fits now and he's like
no I give me this no spillage to
spillage with it I want to see those
tits
he likes the jiggle yeah he now he
doesn't have you did oh he did provide
some interesting insight into why he
thinks like that if you paid attention
there in that conversation he said you
know when I was growing up we go to the
movies there's no such thing as nudity
or bikinis it was just the thing was a
you know an open shirt on a woman and
some cleavage so it's like your your
mind it's funny like anything it's all
involved in involving like your
childhood yeah your wires are connected
everything in puberty and then for the
rest of your life that's what turns you
on and and for any guess for everything
like everything that's like that upsets
you there's probably some tie to
childhood you know yes well I was
listening to shirley manson and Joe
Rogan talked about how when in your
adolescence is a Marilyn yeah no and
Cheryl a man's a winner you develop your
musical tastes and adolescents yeah and
because that's like a formative time for
you that's why you tend to like the same
music that you started in mind
absolutely no I say me I don't like
anything past nineteen ninety-four yeah
I may be like the stroke yeah or like
you find this or that that you yeah but
basically yeah you like this era I was
just listening to goth music that I
liked when I was fourteen in the kitchen
before we did this and it's still it's
still my jam so my mom jamming
what's wrong with the is it the phrase
my jam yeah of course but that's cool I
thought it's a cooler cool what am I
supposed to say like I don't know and
that's my song my band there you go
I'm a jam my jam that's my jam I'm so I
have so many things to share because I
went to mom virtu denaburg yeah with my
BFF Shana and I did a lot of I did a lot
of big girl things
you sure did I smoked pot for the first
time and like two nannies and when I say
that I mean I took one tiny little hit
yeah it affected you right yeah and we
got crazy we watched the Twilight movie
so the first one Vision Quest
we did yeah Riu Team Edward Team Jacob
um I used to be Team Edward and then I
go to Jacob and then I go back what yeah
I said Jacob and you said absolutely not
team member forever
why don't like to Edward abandons her at
some point in the movies like he kind of
you just neglect her I was fuckin gotta
eat man it's not like he's like yeah he
does pussy eaten
oh you think he went to go find other
box other human be verse ya know he's
chased he's not the dollar it's a
Christian I don't know thing about
though yeah wife took me there's like 10
movies would do it nah I'm good it's not
for dudes I like Harry Potter movies
those are elements that I like that a
lot who's your favorite character I
don't know I like I like I just I'm
fascinated by it we got into it a couple
Christmases ago yeah you watch that
first one you're like that's cute
but then as the stories progressed it
actually is just well first of all it's
amazing filmmaking right so you know
they they really kill it as far as that
goes and then the stories get better and
you just get invested in it I mean I saw
I liked it yeah and it's a it's a
wonderful hero's journey and I like
Professor Snape his teeth from
me of yours just the bottom row that he
didn't have done yeah God he shows him
professor snape know what's the reactors
name just maybe you dead right yeah he's
dead yeah he was such an amazing actor
happy to watch talks I could really
watch him acting anything right now it's
father I have I got his name is that hot
to the iron know what he was so
disdainful of the children would you
really I liked a lot and he's super goth
in which he like that I like the
original Dumbledore was was amazed ii
Dumbledore you're like Alan Rickman
that's his name
that was his name God he's a good actor
I know he died like last year pretty
young to be to die when did he die how
old Alan Rickman was 60 right now yeah
well he wasn't old at all on me what are
you dying he died 69 come on dude that's
not even old bro pancreatic cancer
oh that's a nasty one fuck for some this
fax did huh yeah the valta such amazing
you know voice control right the way
that he would deliver a line income
control he would come so hard I may
never be something nice right now why
would you do that you're ruining this
moment it's really terrible that you'd
do that it's just remember those
shrieking Mandrake's that's almost there
[Music]
which Harry Potter movie is this one two
third right where Hermione hits Hubert
and I'll do a train on happiness there's
me when Ron Harry bang come on how she
goes from
teenager to adult right for graduation
and for being away ceremony yeah and
then the lady from Downton Abbey this
McGuirk visit McGonagall you comes into
the lessons oh yeah this is her
graduation ceremonies sirmione drinks a
special potion that they're then they're
like now you're a witch
yeah it's great great there you go a
very special moment we need to be
reviewing all the movies I feel like we
could do a better job than that Siskel
and Ebert yeah I think those two fags
oops
I'm not supposed to say that word
anymore I know you can't help yourself
alright let's get into it right let's
get into it it's Siskel and Roper I
don't know what Roper and Ebert yeah
there's a couple of dead I don't know
any actually two are dead Wow remember
when he had already two guys are dead
yeah what's the original Cisco and Roper
no sickle he was going Ebert well then
Siskel died then Ebert got sick he was
all like that because he had like his
jaw removed and then he died that was
you made now that's your hope I may have
said f AG just now maybe I'll just spell
it you can say it f AG and then you used
to make fun of his mouth cancer because
I did not I fond of his MA my god you
did for a year I didn't make fun of that
he had cancer I I made light of the fact
that I wouldn't have photographed him
because it wasn't a good look it's not
you should have been on television yeah
when you when your face is that mess
Howard like when you're really old sick
yeah when you're when you're dying it's
like I don't know why these me you know
who I think had had a pretty good system
for it was a Johnny Carson when he
retired you never saw a picture of him
again if unless like someone hunted him
down yeah that's good yeah so he got he
got old and died you never knew what he
looked like
yeah nothing these guys now that are
like you know either sick or super old
yeah I got to be in the spot its sonar
cific it is endorsed it is it's
narcissism Richard Simmons is kind of
ducking out and I think people aren't
letting him they're not letting him but
then there was
there was a there was a rumors that
somebody was you know taking advantage
of them and all that yeah that the
housekeeper had kidnapped him or
something like that I don't know but
Simmons has the right idea because he's
aging and he just you know everyone
wants to remember him is that fitness
guy in the dolphin shorts yeah you don't
want to think of him as old Zsa Zsa
Gabor - she kind of faded out buddy - oh
come on so I'm just so excited to be
there's a lot to cover we'll go over at
all
here we go if I was already so all you
Arabs camel jockey I wouldn't do that
who is Randy don't bring anyone love
into this no motherfucker welco welcome
to your palms house with Tom Segura Tina
to yourselves
[Music]
gosh guys nice yeah this is a I guess
he's some type of Jesus protest cowboy
yeah looks like he's on a college campus
that's what I understand like that guy
giving him the finger oh yeah
nobody likes him really there's so much
going on this is a Jesus protest he goes
the campus basically to provoke people
you know fine yeah no better Harry
Potter for a moment sure don't you feel
like Hermione and Harry would have been
a better couple than Ron Weasley and
Hermione yeah of course yeah Hermione is
like up here she's intelligent she's hot
and then Rob what kind of a loser
yeah but didn't they couldn't I mean who
did who did I mean I like Ron but
eventually in the final one who do they
show Harry with right he's like an adult
and he's with fashion lady he has an
Asian girlfriend no no but in the final
one they do like a flash forward where
he's an adult and his kids member hi
he's with anyways Lee Jenni yeah so he
and Ginny Weasley's you know that family
then they hook up she's younger than him
so that's why they don't really hook up
because there's no there's no grass on
her field yet but then once the grass
grows green then back to it right here
that's the final movie the last thing
then there's a you know there's a whole
new series shut up yeah what do you mean
yeah I therefore correction there's a
nude isn't it you're messing with me
know what's the show what is it I forget
I mean I did eight the sum of HP let me
see now I like Ron Weasley don't get me
wrong he's he's charming he's sweet he's
vulnerable but I just feel like Hermione
such a winner and Ron's kind of like man
like kind of not when are like Harry you
know I feel like Harry and Hermione R
equals um Ginny's cool she's all right
but let's see what the dance is called
she's working on two new novels the
native Jane Wizarding community was
particularly gifted an animal and plant
magic I thought you're joking no I'm
serious
she's doing a whole new series men
Native American stuff the writing is an
insult it what episode stand the memory
so Harry Potter spin-off films right
cool
fantastic beasts and where to find them
so yeah this movie's coming as a new
series coming she did a bunch of shit
now it's a Native American theme does
that mean we're going to see a lot of
dream catchers you know I don't like
that aesthetic I don't know western
aesthetic we going to see a lot of bolo
ties I don't know I don't know I hope
not a hey Bo time I let a k so that's
enough for me to turn off a movie me too
yeah I hate I hate somebody and they're
wearing one yeah it's not gonna be a
long conversation and also on hair on Oh
Twilight yeah Jacob gives her a
dreamcatcher for her bed and I that's
immediately when I was like no Team
Edward what that's when you switch
that's the first time I felt real
anything I can't blame you I don't like
those they're ugly yeah stupid I said if
I was racist
that's all you white people cracker you
give a fuck what you got
I was a racist I saw all your Mexican
shit mr. Sandifer
this new hour just feels like my hour I
yeah that is by the way a big big week
first big words I know I got some tweets
people are like are you doing Bill Maher
things are you Bill Maher like I would
just drop that willy-nilly I do not know
know what he problem with how he said it
is that he didn't like like he was a
black comic yeah to say that yeah he did
he did yeah but also a little bit a
little bit of delivering a joke like
that is you do kind of if you're going
to say it you got to kind of really go
for it did he not go for it no no no I'm
saying like he that's how you deliver if
you're going to you're going to say that
line the way he did it you can't have
acid well tell people with the the bit
is because you don't know their dessert
I'm not going to say anymore you're
welcome
we'd love to have you work in the field
with us working part of that
I'm a house nigger did say da not girl
because it's a joke but it is like it's
both I mean look it's not the craziest
thing I really I kind of liked it
actually when I saw and I go oh I I get
it like he's like we're gonna feel yeah
I get it I'm not going to say you're not
going to get me to Bill Maher Eliza I'm
not I mean I'm never offended no it
doesn't but I mean I understand when
people get upset it's funny I feel like
a lot of comics black comics not
offended now I cannot see I got in heard
no one bring it up I was at the store
after this know no one gives a shit you
know it's white people that are
generally outraged no I saw a lot of
black people outraged but not black
comedians no right not the comic black
comics don't go like I cannot believe
that I could eat a comic you just went
for it
you know what's so funny when I was
working on that TBI show with Marlon
Wayans and a lot of black comedians and
that guy came out the owner of the
lizard the Lakers at the time no no the
Clippers yes there's and his girl I was
seen with a black guy and he called them
and he used em word basically is that
what happened or she taped him so it was
a Donald sterling Durling I just
recorded him saying like you know I
don't like you being don't bring black
people to the you know and like I you
know it didn't I mean he was pretty
overtly racist about a lot of stuff yes
he was like I don't even care for you
fuck other guys don't bring him to this
fucking game the black guys to the game
yeah yeah so so that happened and I was
I was let them see me which is crazy so
I was working with a bunch of black
people at the time on that budget median
since I'm not one of them were offended
they're like oh yeah that's just normal
like white people are racist they were
offended at the fact that she ratted him
out yeah yeah but she had snitched on
him George I thought was really funny
like you don't even fazed by never like
now white people are just racist what's
a given yeah like that mean a lot of
people think that yeah I mean I'm saying
that that white people are super racist
yeah I think every you know whatever
they really cause the shitstorm
that Bill Maher's thing yeah yeah he
really fired up about it I just don't
he's not my favorite personally yeah I'm
not a huge fan
I think people also you know what they
get more upset about than him saying it
is when people assume like they there's
they think that he has given himself a
pass in other words that he has the card
you know like the whole card to say what
he wants yeah yeah and it and it it's
that point of view is further blown up
by the fact that he publicly dates black
women so he's always Tom's wristlet so
there I think there's part of a like
this sentiment of like do you think just
because you have sex with a lot of black
women that that gives you that Liberty
like you're still not you know granted
the freedom to say what you want that's
what I think a lot of people can get up
which I 100% agree that point of view of
being like you're not in the group you
know yeah you can't and even even like
we can't I always like I can't even
speak on this topic because I got
exactly like you know what that flourish
idea that somebody would say breaking
this town Oh to white people are of
course yeah yeah which you know I
understand that too but I still feel
like you know it's in the it's also in
the realm of comedy so we have some
right well I mean we can talk about
whatever we want I'm not doctor shit
talk super what no I look as a comedian
I always think it's a freedom of speech
I don't give a shit say which there's so
many things I've heard in comedy
sometimes by my favorite comedians who
say sexist jokes really that doesn't
stop me from liking them you just go
okay that's not you know hey that's not
for me community or male we don't care
is kind of stuff differently yeah like
whenever somebody says a joke and they
get in trouble you're still like okay
because we've heard so many worse things
and so many versions of that already
yeah it's not like I've never hung out
in a group and somebody has made a joke
like bill made nobody's
no one gets worked up about nobody gets
worked up but that's because the
understanding is we all like each other
we're old friends were all in it you
know malice and also like if you're
going for the laugh like I mean people
say awful things going for the laugh
yeah I mean we I was just hanging out
with somebody and they made they were
telling me about lunch with a friend
where another friend had died and the
friend that died was very close to one
of the people at the lunch and the
person told me about how they made a
joke about like a joke about how
somebody at the lunch was responsible
for their friend's death which is like a
harsh joke yeah but you know the guy
went with it because he's a comic and
realized that the comment was made to go
for a joke yeah I mean like yes yes yes
does anybody else would have been like
Jesus yeah that guy just died well the
the intent is always with comedians to
make people laugh just know that the
intent is always for that end for joy at
the end of the day so they may misstep
you may offend too many people here's
what I think number one if it's funny
then it's a success
yeah if the audience doesn't laugh
you've gone too far
and that's how you know Society right
now in this time and space they're not
into what you're doing yeah you can't
say that right now okay that's fine
that's it that now let's go to another
one which is Kathy Griffin yeah who I
love I think she's funny I think she's
had a great career she's fantastic I
think had that Trump thing been funny
yeah it would be a different story
and I think she went too serious and it
was like an arty statement versus like
let's make the shit funny imagine if it
were funny it would have been like a
home run yeah you know that's the only
thing I think and you know openly like I
have disdain for Trump I think he's a
fucking embarrassment and a buffoon you
can't stand them yeah at all and I don't
think it's okay I don't think it's okay
to do that to a sitting president
because you can't pick and choose based
on your preferences when it's okay like
to do that to make that gesture it's not
that I'm personally outraged
just that like you have to you have
respect for the office of president yeah
and if you are doing like decapitation
portrayals of a sitting president you
it's not okay to do I don't I don't feel
like you feel like it's more of a threat
it's like it's like I don't like a death
threat yes I mean and not to a degree I
just feel like it's in such poor taste
to do that regardless of whether or not
you agree or disagree right as in their
point of views and and by the way I
thought it was I was it was grossly done
when Obama was president there was all
these I saw you know noose lynch minions
and they'd had little effigies and and I
thought that was well Ted Nugent's been
hanging presidents and effigy for I
think it's gross to do I don't think you
should do it like I said it's not that
I'm personally worked up about it right
I just feel like you have to have some
standard of how you treat a sitting
president you can say what you want
about them obviously not threatening
them I feel like you can rip them apart
however you feel about how stupid they
are and how they're completely you know
out like just not at all capable of of
their job and that how every decision
they make is is absolutely insane and an
embarrassment and you don't think
they'll make it even through it to
anything you want to say about it when
you start like decapitating them and
showing right right right it's just it's
so it's beyond classless it's it's just
it's so disrespectful to do to the head
of state I don't actually do it I just
only interesting interesting I tend to
differ with you and only because I'm
just going free association here when
communism fell a big symbol of that was
taking down the statues and beheading
the statues taking down the symbolism of
the oppressor of the thing you don't
agree with so I don't know with Cathy
but it's also a statue is usually of a
former first night it's already the
powers already been you served for me
it's a revolutionary thing
where you you're about to overthrow the
power structure and that's like a symbol
you have a recycling decapitated Reagan
head
yeah because you're saying like whatever
okay I hate him he's also dead
he's gotta know but if you have the
current sitting president and you're
decapitating them I don't really feel
like that's I don't know I don't think I
get I get that you're sending a message
and it's a it's a strong one but I think
you have to have some level of respect
for someone who's in power of the motor
yeah I may have to agree to disagree on
this one Segura I don't think you have
to you're with you shouldn't not be able
to say crazy shit yeah you just think
this the imagery is is not respectful
well that lends itself to more things
like that that that's one of the reasons
why I think it's like it gets a little
crazy yeah start decapitating a
president in obviously artistically
right smearing blood all over and then
that fires up people who agree with that
sentiment then it just lends itself to
them I mean I it just can make that type
of action more acceptable may have like
your inciting violence in the center
very fighting yeah you're inciting
arctan crime related to to go along
those lines
I don't know III okay what about just
disrespect now I like the ones remember
that artist who had him with a tiny
peanut seed and that's the thing is that
if it's disrespectful it's funny but if
it's violent yeah then maybe that I
don't think you shouldn't be able to
disrespect the president so do you not
like the naked tiny Peter I love that
one oh well that disrespect I'm saying I
don't feel like you shouldn't be allowed
to disrespect them I feel like when you
have islands like really extreme violent
depictions yeah of you're sitting
president yeah I don't know out of
merriness that's I don't think that
really helps fair enough well she
certainly got the backlash for it by the
way I the backlash that I thought would
come from the Decapitator thing would be
things like what I'm saying like hey I
think that's pretty crazy that you're
decapitating our president right you
know as much as I'm not
fan I think that's pretty crazy I didn't
think she would have to do a press
conference and that she was openly
weeping in the well okay just so you
know I am a little familiar with how
Cathy's dealt with things in the past
yeah he tends to be very dramatic I will
say that because I remember when she
lost she took over with Joan Rivers show
and joy ever passed Joan Rivers past and
you know she got fired from that show or
quit or something and she made it a big
she will be returned yeah exclusive and
emotional so she's basically fueling it
yes to get the press enter yes and I
think and let's be honest that Kathy's a
very provocative comedian she likes to
talk some shit she likes crocheted
that's her whole thing and I think with
the Trump thing she was looking for a
little like ooh this is going to zing
this is going to cause a buzz and I
think it was a little too much buzz you
know I'm saying - blow back but again if
it were funny I just been I feel like it
would have been a hit I know I'd be sad
later when I you know that but I guess I
kind of missed part of it like I saw the
image I didn't blink of it when I didn't
give a shit yeah I just saw like oh she
hates him like so more people didn't get
it who cares I mean like I really was
just like I don't care then there was
like oh dear Kathy Griffin is in trouble
and I was like okay and then when I saw
that like there's going to be an
appalling yeah but I get I get that that
you I don't think you should have
violence encouraged to sitting heads of
state I don't think it's a good idea no
no yo yeah well I you know I feel bad
for I like her and I hope that this kind
of smooths out I don't know what's she's
applying comic dude I know I mean what a
Glenn it let her have a gig show did
she'll be fine yeah she'll be fine
what's the law she doesn't get the host
fuckin New Year's Eve was any other wow
big shit she's got many other jobs
she'll be fine do you want to host that
no I'd rather blow my brains out really
wouldn't you do you think of anything
first of all they have to say nothing
for five hours like well this sure does
look like a full house tonight Anderson
right behind me you'll see the ball and
nearly
what are you fucking talking about for
five hours I blow my fucking brains out
yeah coming up next one Direction's
going to sing their hit song like oh my
god terrible I was fucking kill I better
talk about the ETI tours like endlessly
man she tours constantly she's
publishing book of somebody very sick
doesn't need I'd fucking she's fine
I know somebody was like huge fall you
know her careers over crews over and I
was like why because none of her fans
would stop buying tickets and Longford
she's beloved she'd the gay community
loves Kathy Griffin she's doing theater
that's fine she's doing great
okay so right now there are no toward
well she cancelled them she did she did
when this happened I because the death
sir I said everything absolutely I think
it's a little heavy for her right now so
she canceled them she's doing she's
doing fine she's really SIA but none of
them would stop buying tickets of court
the fans probably like her more of
course because they're you know they're
probably anti Trump as well it's
fantastic
yes she was I mean I guess who knows if
these are still because these are some
of these are ways away community art
center st. George theater in New York
yeah this is doing fine she's doing fine
all right you know that's it was lighten
up camel jockey do that Wendy I like
videos I wouldn't do that and he goes
that was never telling them how come I
would never do that as I'm doing that
what's with the gay rainbow flag I don't
know what sounds like I'm you know it's
funny he's a he's a college level Kathy
Griffin though he's just like he's a
provocateur though he's just doing that
get a reaction
yeah do that she's got the jokes though
she's no I know but it is to incite a
reaction that's that's all he's doing
yeah I wouldn't do that
I love that people get mad at that that
guy like he's just a fucking subway act
you know what I mean like
lunatic in a fucking car and he's going
to where they like they didn't come see
him he went to like that Student Union
outside they're not paying $30 a ticket
for that shit fuck no man dummy big
dummy can I tell you what I discovered
you know how you and I talk about how we
suffer for years before we makes light
like we would use one phone charger in
the house versus just by four or five
yeah so for 40 years I've been wearing
shoes without socks yeah and I fucking
hate it I hate it so much my feet are
very sweaty and I fucking ruin shoes and
my feet are sweaty all day and I just
hate hate hate it so I was like can I
talk to you about that I was like weak
to people like do you wear socks and
slip-on shoes and you go yeah you can
buy invisible socks yeah they're like
barely cover your foot yeah
did you just fine I just bought them on
Amazon using our banner your mom's house
podcast calm you just click on the
banner at the top of the homepage and
it's changed my whole life
amazing and now I like I'm so much
happier about it my feet don't sweat all
day yeah it only took 40 years to figure
out that that's what people have been
doing you I mean you've seen me with
little ankle socks how many times and
then but you know what I think in my
fucked up Eastern black brain what those
are not for me all right those are what
fancy people have a crazy brains do that
your brain will do that to you I don't
deserve ankle socks
what are you bougie I went to that
chiropractor the human mechanic yeah and
I've noticed that like I'm getting a
slight hump at the top of my back and I
was just like well I'll just be there
like one of the first thing he said he's
like oh yeah I can get that out of you
yeah make a couple adjustments so that
amazing any better
sorry better but that we just accept the
battery years right now just that will
hurt sad no it's my other two that I
just the crown I just got replaced that
thing hurt me for like five years
yeah five years I would have to floss
around it it would hurt every time I ate
something that would get food
get caught in it and I was like well
guess I have to suffer it's expensive to
replace a crown I can't do that just let
your teeth hurt enough hurt a lot um yes
so right now is a fucking big month big
mud big words yeah you're uh you only
have a couple weeks left I'm so pumped
first of all I want to thank everybody
that came out to Denver Comedy Works a
big shout out to the mommies who work at
the Comedy Works apparently they're huge
fans of the show and they played mom's
house music all weekend and it was such
a thrill and thank you to all the
mommies who came out it was truly a
wonderful weekend so coming up I've only
got June 16th and 17th at the punchline
and man-friend disco to run my hour
before I tape it oh I do one more show
at the Uhuru mcflip airs comedy club in
Burbank June 22nd June 24th is the big
day you can put your name on a list and
they will contact you and you will get
tickets to my tapings June 24th in
Seattle at the Showbox theater go mm
ranch calm click on the link there put
your info in and they will contact you
like I said there's two shows seven and
9:30 and I'm really stoked you guys I'm
like I'm fucking ready to do this double
barrels Tommy's going to come with me
and Sammy I'll be up there you're going
to massage me and keep me calm yeah it's
gonna be awesome I'm going to be in a
fuckin frenzy that day I'm really
talking about I'm still happy for you um
it's without you Jean I would be nothing
please because of you
please you're my Jean I have a huge
announcement you're non-binary I'm
non-binary I'm Polly this Friday the 9th
not only am i doing a showing tux in
Arizona the next day is Reno and the
next day is Pechanga in Temecula I don't
want a Spanish word for pussy it is but
not only am i doing those shows this
weekend but on Friday
September 9th all my fault eights going
on sale Wow my second leg of the no
teeth no entry tour going sale why it's
a lot oh I'm coming to Lincoln Nebraska
Lincoln Oklahoma City Oh Springfield
Missouri ah Oakland California okay
Denver Colorado number Albany New York
Redding Pennsylvania Portland Maine Oh
China a stereo Canada Oh Ann Arbor
Indianapolis Cleveland st. Louis Fargo
Albuquerque San Antonio Austin Port
Chester New York New York
Buffalo Riverside Big Show in Los
Angeles and fart Knicks Arizona Wow all
those are on sale this Friday June 9th
go to Tom Segura comm click on the tour
page and get your tickets that's it you
that's a lot of Tours a lot and then
your monster Eliana's I got mom
Australia is your mom's house alive
let's not be I want to plug those two
days yeah there's a there's aa ggest
23rd is in breast Paul's Beach Florida
at the Palm Beach improv we have one in
July right let me I'm looking it up
right now we have a July 1 I love one
our internet firm vine July 9th
Irvine improv and then August 23rd at
West Palm Beach yeah that should be
really fun a lot of fun I can't wait to
do those that'll be good yeah it's gonna
be exciting July 9 there you go yeah
Tom I learned how to do boomerang this
morning yeah it's cool it's best six
months after I did um like how you
didn't even you know when I got on this
thing called Friendster it was really
cool I forgot to uh for you I had some
setup great for your channeling your
tour guide it did go see Christina do
stand-up now we're talking
Wow thank you I know like Viktor it's
very me thank you my dick did go see
Christina do a stand-up now we're
talking by the way this is one of my
favorite things we didn't get to last
week we had my parents on top dog and
I'm sorry and at a certain point you
know it went on long enough but there
was one point afterwards where I was
trying to show them non-binary things
just to get their reaction on it I
looked that up so it's 41 minutes in
that we've been sitting here my dad was
there my mom was here I'm here we have I
playing clips and it's that it's the
first time when my dad goes I don't hear
anything and this is when we discover
that for 41 min now he didn't have
headphones play Robin never said
anything picture they were on his ear
and we're having this conversation can't
rely he just never mentioned its
definitions here because people will
hear the term non-binary and not I know
what that means and in fact some people
here non-binary and say well why not
trans man or trans woman how do you
answer those two questions you don't
hear anything no what do you mean no
hear anything you didn't hear any of
that no did you hear that moment yeah
they were in here words no okay can you
hear me in the microphone right now you
know you don't hear me right now you
haven't heard anything this whole time
yeah yeah yeah you pulled your headphone
out oh where does it go in here what he
did what I never had it in there the
whole time
no yes he did when he was laughing would
it blunt
yeah I see he remember he laid back and
he put it up okay can you hear me now
now yeah I never had
actually this whole time no I didn't
actually
wait it okay sorry what to play these
okay
this how to be here I was okay with him
never and this is ever he didn't even
hear what the fuck you were saying go
like right now he just heard like muted
sound because he put headphones on but
had nothing taken but did it wow that's
amazing
never was what I want too much but
apropos our discussion earlier of like
well guess it's just not that's how it
goes it's also exactly like who he is
yeah I don't really need area as long as
I hear my own thoughts yeah we really
care yeah and then this is great this is
when I so I got Charlie to say that and
then it was I was trying to get top dog
to say I wrote I had this joke an improv
joke and if you ever saw the people's
mayor which is on my YouTube page where
it's kind of like this parody of Rob
Ford the old Toronto Mayor that I made a
couple of years ago with some really
talented people you know we would
improvise lines and I had one where I'm
playing a guy and I go hey how come I
come if you think you're gonna fart you
shit there's a name for that what about
when you think you're going to shit and
you fart there's no name for that so I
try to get top dog to say it this is
what it's like to try to get him to to
say here we go home you know that's the
only I know there's been another song I
made for you but I don't think where it
is that's okay
so will you say for me though do you
like big tits let's say do you like big
tits go see Christina I guess she's
wrong yeah okay yeah see like big tits
bro see Christina assuming the same
thing good oh go see Christina do
stand-up okay yeah okay my dick did go
see Christina doing stand-up
now we're talking we go now we try at
top and you say how come sometimes you
think you're going to fart and you shit
and there's a name for that what about
when you think you're going to shit and
you only fart what's that called
okay when you think you're gonna fart
and you should there's a name for that
when you think you're going to shit and
you only part what's that called do you
think that that's pretty like you think
you could split that out right now fight
okay how come when when you fart but
shit there's a name for that the how
come you shit and you don't fart in
phrase you struggled I can't repeat
lines I yes okay because the fighting is
I thought it was pretty easy to remember
I wouldn't know
he really but my mommm resident means
I'd have to read it yeah I can't repeat
things back if you had it written down I
could memorize it I have to come when
you fart and you shit but there's a name
for that no no no when you think you're
going to fart and shit how come when you
think you got fart yeah and you say that
that doesn't matter for that but then
you shit and you think no no no what you
think you're gonna say yeah you're so
disordered when you think you're gonna
shit and then you fart
what's that call yeah can you do it all
together though I'm not sure she's okay
she's an actor she's great that nothing
understanded he says how come when he
thinks he's going to fart but he shit
but it's a name for that and she's
wondering he keeps asking me all the
time
how come when she thinks he's going to
shape it on a chart there's no name for
that perfect Shiva you can do that it
how come well I'm going to fart and I
shit there's a name for that
what's a call when you think you're
going to shit
and you only part don't take off that's
it you got a perfect nose really good
that's and you put it that's how I was
here dead
that was perfect what is that called
that's the thing so when you think
you're going to fart and shit it's
called a shart no I did another what's
that name for this so there you go
and I'm like oh I should what about you
I have to take a shit and you only fart
there's no name for that there really is
there should be though okay I'm thinking
we can capitalize on that I think our
audience your great idea we're going to
call it what are we going to call that
okay so when you you think you're going
to shit but you only fart what does that
mean cause yes okay so char lay it out
when you think you're gonna fart and you
shit it's called a shark
everybody knows that right say like oh
you feel confidence to fart oh okay uh
but what about when you're like I gotta
take a shit great now you just sit down
you fart right it's only a
disappointment yeah but there should be
a name for this I know I know okay let's
sing it's not called a dump
it's called uh it's like a hump or at
along with first once yeah yeah it's not
a shit but uh flip my thump descent was
a pump a stomp a thump is like a fart
that was adopted of a dump alright fun
there you go it's a fun to thump a
fucked life our day when I should have
dumped yeah I felt oh my god do you
think how excited is my god when
somebody comes back to the bet from the
best how was it pumped yeah yeah how
excited you think my dad is winning paly
a hard dollars for my education and we
just came up with funk
well of you if you send him some of the
responses in these emails I seem to be
very proud of you yeah dad look at all
these pomp responsibly
look at all this bumped and uh bob is
good my life um because if thump sounds
like a disappointed the want want war
yeah gets a disappointment to fob yeah
if I wanted to dump but I farted I fuck
no I mean that that works really good
work expression I'm okay
it was only a thump yeah right or could
have been better but it
just a farms at the pump yeah no you
know what that is I was hoping now or
but iPhone it's just a fart that's why
because you're saying I went to shit but
I just farted then all you did was fart
you didn't create anything new with a
shark you're creating a new entity
correct it's a fart with shit in it but
it's a fart that had expectations so
it's not just a fart
I mean a farts all that came out of you
but it's tied to a bigger idea that's so
you're saying we created a third idea
being the failed the failed dump yeah so
it's a fart that failed in its mission
to push out the shit because my mother
used to say thoughts blushed the shit
out right so when it fails it's a
failure fart in other words yeah
interesting yeah as deep bro
we got to put this on the other show
yeah pretty good man well let's make
some submissions guys write us and let
us know your mom's podcast at gmail.com
what the word is for when you know house
it's your mom's pod right we can get
that one here's uh speaking of fart sup
mommies here's an email I recently had a
shower time conversation with my beloved
wife regarding a very special type of
fart only experienced in shower time
situations I will tell you after I told
my wife I did this she gave me the look
like I crossed a line I guess I can only
describe it has fart gargling
and it's really special sometimes when I
need to fart while showering I jut I
gently cut my hand over my ass holding
water in a cup like fashion before
letting loose the trumpets this results
in a gargle like situation that is
really neat upon telling my wife about
this because I have never done it in
front of it she said I must be the only
one on earth that does such a thing I
can't be the only one please consult the
mommies of the world I hope you genders
keep it hot with your genes in the
clouds pk
I'll tell you this I've never done
American but I find it fascinating I'm
willing to bet there's a lot of
listeners that either do that a version
of that or have their own unique fart
kind of our situation
of course now didn't you do a thing
where you played the trumpet where you
manipulated your butt cheeks and then
maybe it made different sound oh I
really like doing that I really I really
like that I like to move my leg and also
play with my butt cheeks yeah because
the pitch will change okay you can even
do it by squatting because you know your
cheeks will move as you as you move so
if you have to fart you just do a half
squat yeah you'll hear you'll hear the
pitch change you know what's really
interesting about you is that you
believe slick stuff neat stuff you're
really a risk-taker with these farts
because personally I'm afraid to move
too much around because what if the
brown comes down yeah I'm just afraid
I'm confident when's the last time you
sharted hmm
it's been a little while year two and
yeah I'm a little nervous to do all that
fancy stuff now I almost had a bad one I
had this upper respiratory infection in
a couple weeks ago yeah and I took an
antibiotic that liked it one of the side
effects like you might get severe
diarrhea but I'm somebody that always on
those side affecting just never gets
ignored yeah and I taste dude I got a
harsh bout of it so I had to quit the
antibiotic two days later it was still
kind of filtering through me yeah I
remember one of my first farts yeah
often I went I went for it as I was
going for it I go oh you might have done
that too soon and it's still you know
hung in there it was interesting
interested it was it was dicey you know
what I've been having lately remember
when I first gave birth to Ellis I
couldn't hold in farts yeah it's kind of
come back yeah and I don't know why yeah
but either that or I'm just not as
concerned with who hears the farts
anymore I don't care yeah I've been
farting very freely lately and it feels
great yeah I don't care
a Iseman Shana told me this weekend that
was alarming what she said that in her
world the double pipe classic is not as
rare as we say it is that she has them
like every few much it doesn't know what
she's talking about that's what I said
that's what I said mm classic very rare
right she's probably thinking of like a
1/2 but like an equal exit that's very
rare
well to get the timing precise on
something like that it's really
coincidence a lot of really chance burp
fart right fart burp right you know but
to have them go uh at the same time very
rare it's very and especially if you can
try to force it you can swallow it it's
not that's not a truth it's not the
nature of a double yeah you can be like
oh I got a fart in the chamber I know
I'm about to fart I'm gonna swallow some
air right that's not a fantasy maybe
that's what she's doing yeah I feel like
she's forcing the issue i Shauna I
wonder if you're not it has to be
organic that's the whole fun of the
double pipe this is funny that just came
in because blue band prepped this yeah
and he didn't even know what was going
to happen today and here's what I mean
he read that gene it says hey Hitler's
after living through the hashtag Thomas
fat bird is fat era I've admitted that I
too am fat I have been as Christians Oh
would say making Fitness regularly so as
an act of self bribery oh sorry oh gee
oh oh oh so Ella says no oh very cute
okay as an act of self bribery and
motivation if I go to the gym and make
Fitness every day in a month
I am rewarded with a new podcast t-shirt
may was my first month and I have
ordered my brand-new stannum uh shirt I
look forward to sweating through it like
a monster in seven to 10 ish days thanks
mommies for keeping my humor in the
toilet and my spirits highest Fox animal
shout-out to my main jeans Mike pio pio
lling it down also Tina please come to
Philly I've seen Tommy and burnt and
helium I need some east coast meanest
mommy love wishing you both fours Sarah
thank you censor and good for you Sarah
that you're working on your fitness
that's very great that's amazing
we've gotten people always weigh-in they
tell us like I wish this was she did
that with regard to shirts one of the
things we've heard a lot is I wish you
had something for summer
and I wish you had something for Fitness
right and so we paid attention to it and
now we have a new fitness shirt
it's a summertime kind of fit in this
shirt in that it is a tank top that is a
little picture so see if I can bring up
a bigger version of it but basically it
is a tank top it says I'm making fitness
and it has an actual Fitness dude making
a kicky foot on it keke playing we also
did a women's version because people
sometimes say like oh you only have men
so look at that it says I'm making
Fitness just like an Eastern Bloc or
would say your mom's house underneath it
this guy's kicky pudding let them so
making Fitness try to make it so that
you can wear it to make Fitness in yeah
it's at the gym but you can also wear it
because it's about to be hot as fuck
outside and so this one I wonder why you
can I want to take it there to you you
look great
you see oh there I am you're making your
fitness Jean here I did it in jeans too
so you could see how a real communist
would work out in jeans I drew in my
tank top making I'm doing the heck squat
deadlift by the way super easy to lift
that amount of weight for me okay it's
true just making fitness making fitness
and I'm making fitna go to if you go to
Tom Segura dot-com and you click on the
store you know that's kind of a German
thing my grandmother used to say making
stuff like when you're not used to like
when you when you make makeups when
you're making baking up and you're like
you don't have to make it I guess in
German you know what they say you make
yeah when I stand up in the morning like
no it's you get up also do you remember
stand it so crazy remember last week we
played this thank you she said yeah what
celebrates getting together with someone
becoming Mary but there's no milestone
in society that celebrates scaping
something awful that world happen and go
your own happiness contestants just
called living a good life because some
people are Erica Anderson
of course lives in Brooklyn also married
herself it's a log it's hard not to
adopt whatever society's messages are so
that was last week yeah well hey mommies
I heard you guys talking about salami
and it reminded me of this girl my my
girlfriend was telling me about she was
a part-time makeup artist any time she
and my girl worked together she comes
home mentally drained lunatic
apparently marries herself yearly now
very expensive retreat she goes on and
her and her sisters marry themselves in
some group ceremony this girl does not
have any friends course and my girl
feels bad for her so she listens to her
when she goes on these hour-long rants
about how terrible her life is she's a
good-looking girl but completely batshit
crazy love the podcast Anton
that's why cuz she's fucking crazy
exactly be with her yeah and that's why
you marry yourself well nobody wants to
marry you because your mom and you are
the only two thank you marriage material
yeah and she's bitches and bitches about
her life that's what he's saying that
she's in fuckin unhappy twat it's so
narcissistic to - I'm going to marry
myself like that especially to make
people attend that should do that inside
God you should go yeah you should go out
in the woods and be like yeah this tree
married me to myself embarrassed don't
don't have everybody come to this you
should be ashamed and have the healthy
amount of shame attached to that that's
real crazy I mean isn't life about
giving to other people you know your
husband to your wife to your kids to
your dogs your cats whatever yeah it's
about giving not taking you fuck Scott
you also last week it's fucking crazy
sounds yeah fuck don't marry yourself
just keep fucking talking people till
you find the one yeah you know and
that's the problem is they don't want to
get their lives and don't want to go to
therapy to figure out why they're so
miserable
yeah instead they go but I'm a strong
woman nobody can handle me I'm so strong
like no boo-boos interesting accent and
I'm strong mmm why can't I handle me
there's this okay I'll tell you why
there's a girl on Instagram yeah those
black girls I follow and she's always
posting that I like or post but she'd
always complain that men don't like her
because she's so strong that's because
you're too
want to toss kind of shitty yeah out of
your mind yeah last week we also
discussed we showed you shacks
horrendous employed Oh his size 22 God
demon foot and that was fun
why it's a Triple D slut since he's got
was divorced 22 feet so I don't know he
divorced but he's after he plays the
field he had a good time said
girlfriends but also brought about a
discussion that maybe shacks dong yes
there's because there's been stories you
know there's been stories that not that
it's like a you know a baby dick just up
for being on a giant right right it
might not be impersonal or stories about
this really
yeah people I've heard room like I've
heard everything from like it is really
small to like I actually got to sports
reporters that I know texted me this
week and they said hey man
I listen to the podcast I've seen Shaq
naked multiple times and it is not smart
really they're like no it's not well
yeah yeah well that's good I trust the
sports reporter do I trust them over
anyone but we did get this email know
how funny this is
I love to see Shaq's dick yeah I
wouldn't you I'm so curious yeah of
course
a few people I'd like to see their dicks
oh there's a lot of people I want to see
their dick really who do you want to see
besides most people me too yeah I feel
like I like to see people naked I think
I'd like to see their genitals yeah I
think it I think I don't know you kind
of but you know what's funny is that any
way that it comes across you're going to
have this in other words let's see you
see somebody you like I've always wanted
to see this person's dick or naked yeah
and they're super confident and they got
a big dick you're like you're like
you'll tie it you'll go oh well that's
why he's so confident but then the same
guy could be super confident with a
little one and it's like I don't know
just if as little you go that's weird
he's confident but he's not like it
still goes one way or the other like you
don't really personalities not an
indicator it's not going to really I
think you make it you make the
assumption that it's the indicator but I
don't know that it necessarily is that's
my point
yeah I hear you I feel like I can tell
what the girls vagina will look like
yeah
based on her face and her build like I
can be like oh that's like a hangar well
I can tell you that confidence thing is
not necessarily tied to that - dick size
know I'm insecure guys the truth one
truth here because I've known both ways
yeah it's not it's not it's not full
spectrum oh god those big Puerto Rican
hogs those guys are full of confidence
but it's not correlated to confidence no
yelling so no because I've known guys
tejada bit larger and they're totally
weak and totally sad and then I known
guys really small Peters who are the
most delightful confident caring you
know but I should I know these Peters so
many so many so many so you had your
saying that you've been with a guy
spectrum you know with guys that had big
ones that were not confident yes
actually the least confident of my
boyfriend's the one who had the most
emotional problems had a pretty girl one
on him
really and you would never guess yeah
yeah I don't think I don't find that now
that I know things no that's that
shocking you know I'm saying I don't
that shocking yeah
well cuz there's other things that go
into somebody's personality and you know
they can have a childhood thing and it's
really how you're raised that it could
be ridiculed for their girthy penis I
just think there's more than the guys
penile size it determines his emotional
mental personality well here's an email
about Shaq's okay this thing is
operating really slow dude I wish we
could do people naked is there an app
right you can like you can guess what
they look like me again maybe one hub
there you go
hey jeans I recently heard a story about
Shaq and his hog someone I know was at a
urinal and none other than Shaq diesel
himself walked up and stood next to him
her name's Aaron pleased me she couldn't
help but look over to witness what he
thought was going to be a black iguana
hanging there and to his surprise it was
a very average size penis act caught him
her looking and said
crazy right huge big words right called
himself huge big word with a tiny dick
and the word sure he made light of it
an average dick on a monster definitely
looks minuscule keep them high and tight
and get it and get a handjob from your
grandpa on a ferris wheel and fuck
purified water love Sam thanks Sam thank
you so I think but I think that's where
the rumors that I heard first came from
it's never that his was tiny is that
he's a legit gigantic human being with a
regular-sized peener maybe it's not even
regular maybe it's definitely above
regular but that it's on a monster right
he's seven one and in his retirement
weight he's probably 340 that's great I
mean that's that's a guy that his head
is probably near those lights up there
you know and is width is it is more than
the width of that doorframe so somebody
like that you're like oh my god it means
it should look like a fucking like one
of these posts right here you know right
so that's what I think it comes from
well Shaquille if you're listening if
you go ahead and send us a picture of
your dick that'd be great you would show
too in person I'm sure I just come over
and show us your dick I don't know if
you do that but I think if you guys
track him down Clemence le he has an LA
residence but he lives primarily in
Florida okay we'll just fly over and
show us your dick no there you heard it
jack hopefully we can never know it but
many famous people listen to our show
that's true Shaquille could be listening
right now if I see that time I would be
like
nice gotta set it off set it off set it
ow
this I got oh my god this I can't help
but but just almost weep when I see
things like this and this is where I am
the biggest advocate for ending your own
life is when I see things like this this
is a roll call I had some job
orientations we're supposed to say your
name uh-huh and you say like what your
interests are and you have to do it
while you're clapping I can tell me no
no no no I think right then I stand up
this is what white people do right then
I'd be like yeah quit even if you were
text me like the baby needs diapers
there's no food at home I'm gonna go rob
somebody right now I think this is why
we dropped out of the system it's pretty
it's exactly meetings like this but a
team-building things God clapping it
quarterly earnings oh my god blow my
fucking brains out are the worst is like
it somebody wrote what would you do if
you were a in the audience know if you
were forced to do a Shibuya roll call I
wouldn't do I go the bathroom and hide
yeah I believe diarrhea I can't do the
Shibuya roll call Shibuya remember like
team-building days or they make you do
like trust falls and all those things
that usually love that team thing that I
got it's not demeaning can't you just
pay me my check and let me go home I
know a couple to work at Whole Foods and
it's all about this team the team team
leader will be here later I can I had
that question for the guy he goes what
our team leader will be hearing okay
like who fucks your team leader I'll use
a general manager yeah okay it's a fancy
word for general manager you're not a
team this is not a fun thing a team
implies fun
all going to be playing a sport later
well that's that's the psychology of
make you think you're having fun and
that we're all in this together well
equal your hierarchy yeah yeah yeah
right there's this little higher he was
a CEO good stock options but yeah where
you get minimum wage it's cool right but
you're a team member
yeah we're all part of team ho if you
get to wear jeans on Friday bri-bri and
Chelsea so fun oh my fuck my name is
bridge I mean this guy I could see him
smiling I don't know how you're smiling
that's all dudes that are like oh boy do
I have to really do this I think they
think that it's that they're getting to
watch cute girls and they're like I'll
cool right and like no no you're
participating in this now oh my god
you're gonna do this my name is Chavez
yeah I like the pirates yeah my name is
free this is so embarrassing oh this is
quite for our house Cooper this is a big
company oh this is terrible look how
depressing it is too under these
horrible neon lights you know these
depressing office lights and it's God
you know what I mean isn't work hard
enough for people like isn't it enough
that you have to wake up every morning
traffic sit there work hard
sit in traffic go home do it again five
days a week and then they have to demean
you with these fucking meetings and make
you sing like a donkey is it demeaning
let these people just do their job and
go home why do you have to fuck with
them no no have some respect my name is
Tom yeah yeah oh shit
yeah I had a shrimp last night yeah it's
gonna come out my dick yeah
Shibuya Kubu my name is Christina yeah
nothing rhymes of Christina great job I
got tips yeah down to my knees yeah I
like this shit
yeah I like the sneeze yeah same so dumb
what do you and what are you going to
share like your intimate lots of people
I like baseball
okay I like to dance give me a chance I
was so fucking mad that's what I would
say I like to fart
yeah and smell it too yeah I cut my
farts in the shower
how's Tom yeah this is a can yeah I'll
say it once yeah but we my money do you
stop clapping and then later sorry like
what like what waiting to fuck you in my
ass man I just end the whole thing and
they're like hey you gotta get out of
here
you're fired you're fired yeah that was
my first day wait Shibuya disabuse ya
dumb shits
boo-yeah boo-yeah what a fucking I hate
stuff like that Shibuya it's real what a
fucking nightmare I don't know try
dentally slow today I finger myself in
the shower yeah yeah I spread my butt
cheeks right yeah if I say yeah yeah I'm
playing with my door all the way I
spread my budget yeah I'll wipe it hard
yeah I shit on a bidet yeah I push and
push like a tard yeah make a bridge and
get over my name is Tom I'm fuckin I'm
proud to come out of this polyamorous
and now I'm excited to share that I'm
bisexual oh thank you for sharing Paul
Oh that'll be great if he's like I'm
Paulie and by yeah I'm also what I'm
muffin on binary yeah their pronoun you
could just ruin like if you had a bunch
of people and they were queued up to say
fucked up things you could ruin their
whole thing it would that would be
fantastic
that'd be the only way to get through
this
and corporate oppression yeah my name is
Tom yeah I like fun times yeah yeah I'm
gonna get married yeah
to my mom what am I marry my mom soon
yeah my name is Christina yeah I'm not
that dumb yeah I drink a lot of con ese
Artie good job I'm going on it come
strike yeah okay okay Christina Jesus
I'm going on a come strong I think if
you did that it's like if you said okay
they wouldn't be able to throw you out
they'd have to like reset yeah I mean
it's respect your pronouns reflect your
pronoun and also like if you were like
yeah I'm really going on this come
strike they'd have to go excuse Christ
like we can't we can't fire her because
there be a lawsuit yeah oh yeah yeah and
fun I know everybody's so fucking in
radom mmm
yeah I like blue yeah there's one more
thing I don't like Jews hey guys why'd
you stop clapping hello I'm like um to
that when they fire you for you're like
you know they fire you for the other one
they're like my name is Tom I could be
bigger
uh yeah god I don't like I go ahead I'm
saying it well I'm gonna get remix in it
next week's song you can you there's all
time that you have said the moving of it
I can't do that how come there's too
many out there of me saying it there are
too many no there's not yeah ha no
there's not
there's too many what are you talking
about go for it no you go for it now you
go you go for it go for it go for you go
for you the graffito for it no way she
doesn't go for Nicolas Nicolas
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I couldn't believe it she was
saying that I'm really in my brain I was
like it's Nicolas there's no way anybody
can say what'd she say oh I can't wear I
wonder how his Danny axe are doing I
don't know it's we gotta look sit low
got a finder see what she's doing Danny
yeah yeah I don't know what she's doing
hey um Nathaniel
nothing actually I want I have the place
I want a shit is I'm not on your mouth
around and in your mouth this is what I
was looking for this is what I'm looking
for here that was the original original
depressing corporate yeah come on I'm
this god I was terrible that was crazy
those are what shann the things you like
yes I love it this place is the worst
I let it work orientation thing in
heaven that a big like corporate retreat
showing you things you like try to get
engaged
[Music]
my social social good job good job guys
searching for the story that'll bring us
into the full fucking song a viral video
that we posted to the grabs the ground
nobody called in for the season
[Music]
what we try to keep from ticking no that
means a stack day looking back with me
[Music]
social that's the guy that wrote it that
guy the other guy yeah he takes full
credit remember in the beginnings like I
wrote this yeah that's my orientation
you guys ready doesn't work here
everybody line up sit down sit down
yeah good doesn't it I feel like this is
how pollution got hired this was amazing
we're gonna have to do it on our own
okay would you rather be in that room
smelling all those smells oh yeah I have
to fuck anybody but that's your
orientation is watching guys fuck each
other you smell it or it's the Shibuya
orientation fuck now be real think about
this
so either be in a bukkake room yeah and
you just you're close how close are you
you're right in the mix you're this
close to guys fucking and sucking and
gross you're not participating yeah you
don't have to its orientation to work
you're going to start working at this
company and this is what they sell
videos but they want you to be familiar
with the product so you have to sit
through a live filming or or Stu Shibuya
so I'm going to work it you know this
company yeah you gotta fucking do the
roll call yeah here's much way
definitely watch that any day definitely
I would watch guys but fucking shitting
on each other smearing the shit on it
over there like hey my name is kaylee
and I like a good time no fuck that
I like the Cubs wow Kaylee you really
dug deep on them yeah I can't wait on
all of us to get to do that they never
share anything truly interesting either
it's all surface level like I like the
color blue everybody knows dipshit so
one of the I know it's fucking so stupid
one of the what do you masturbate to
Kylie like let's hear that remember we
watched the what one of the origins of
getting ban peun or world just finding
him on these interviews yeah I'm talking
about like I'm
I can't hear cunt Brian Brian yes well
you're fucking poor the cat Brian so
that guy has a show called London real
yes and he had on this sexual I don't
know
but tantras kind of teacher guru yeah
and so I haven't seen this yet but
there's clips of this guy breaking down
very handsome
what's that you're very handsome thank
you thank you thank you very beautiful I
like you I like you to remain sure maybe
we can you know time when we practice
what this eye teaches I haven't no I
really have no idea we're talking up
it's good and so the women practice on
the egg what are the men do about the
men the first thing they have to
practicing that we call sharpening they
knife I have an idea what I think I know
okay so the whole key is very simple you
get an oil we call the high go baby oil
baby oil baby right you put it in and
now you put the pit peanuts to warm it
using in the co winter you warm them up
you get hot power okay and you may get a
warm okay and you put it here make sure
all the blood flow okay oh so far like
but now I like what he's going with so
far he playing a hot towel on a painter
which is great one left his own warm it
a warm towel not hot yeah okay bring it
a glut in there now you get the penis
out yeah you pull the skin a lot of
people they never circumstances yeah
38:15 answer so you pull the skin and
you get the oil in the hand and your
right hand cold I need to wrap wrap wrap
wrap especially on the glans penis rub
them I'm throwing it sometime right 50
homes because you make them strong and
not sensitive home okay
so your he said the glands which is near
the tippy top you know right there the
right below the tippy top with your
glands right fifty times one one is
Wi-Fi fifty times left side
if you come from with the time back it
to come down I loving wives how often am
I doing this you have to do every day
until you can control every day
every day anybody can read themselves
that much without home I'm sharpening
the knife you're not all that I'm not
sure okay
all right years I'm traveling tonight
there's a number one number two you have
to learn how to contracting the prostate
gland how do you learn to contract your
prostate gland I have a feeling it's
going to be gruesome Julie to start
doing this why not I don't think you can
control yourself 150 50 that's like 200
strokes on that thing and nothing
happens no way no way it's not possible
to now the endless is differently okay
so people cannot suffer it in bed they
they don't know it is clear on an
earth-based it don't work because
they're anything when you contract the
process and because male g-spot is in
prostate gland right yeah so when you
contract the prostate gland in the front
and you feel anything
activate here so you contract and you
feel here actually now you do it right
now would you have sex with this guy no
no but just because you know he knows so
no what no no take away no just listen
take away like I'm mayor like just I'm
just saying there's no marriage vows
involved it's just like on a physical
level
this guy is a set wiring route and you
know what what if you were promised
listen one of your friends goes I was
with Kim here and I had another things
Kim I don't
I had an earth-shattering orgasm like I
came to the point where I was just like
I I so screaming I had a my leg kicked
through a wall and I wept for an hour
and is the greatest feeling I've ever
had in my life I can set you up with him
would you
here's why I'm going to decline exactly
because I can't get over this guy
aesthetically now you put him and Ryan
Gosling's body yeah absolutely but no
but that's the thing though is what I'm
saying is let's say somebody isn't to
the I attend and stunning to you but
their their ability is through the roof
yeah but for me sex is mental so if I'm
not mentally attracted pacifically
attracted I can't even get there you lay
here cause I know he doesn't say it like
that
he just says God I Clos i right so you
have a little blindfold on like it and
then he's just like kind of like it he's
just gonna like it
I can't believe you don't want this I
don't like him I don't like the vegan
vagina guy I don't like I don't like
Creeper she's a creeper do you guys guy
he's not a nice manly decoration the
special out of the exaggeration is from
the post again contrasting okay so I'm
exercising four people have perfect men
stolen are a problem this one is called
the problem okay
just like my family three hundred
thousand three hundred three hundred
these guys are just you know what
they're called perverts I eat the ass
and pussy all the time I got nothing to
perverts these are guys who like to jerk
their cocks 24/7 and he jerks dicks so
much and he thinks he's a guru he's an
expert on the attacker yes
all now are just overly horny the
question is for me what I led this guy
Jack my dick yes because he's so good at
it and the answer is a resounding yes
okay how about this let's say it's a
woman we put this guy let's say it's him
in but yeah it's like an old-ass woman
there's like that would you marry your
mom mom that's a lady who's got to give
you a handjob would you marry him oh
right right it's her if if I'm being
told this is the greatest thing ever
sure sure it would she wouldn't bother
you know not rapping I mean if I'm
looking at her yeah but what if she's
just like he's like here you know he's
men he come on comes in here come on
close close hi
mopwai shot yeah anyway yeah I don't
know if he's known as the cat that there
you like nothing but boys what you ready
mom yeah yeah I think I would I think so
I did if you want stretch what I do the
those plug-in type laces you want to
stress home how much do you hate it when
they stretch you at the time plated
hated stop stretching me it's the least
relaxing thing and they also forget
because sometimes if I go I'll be like
okay no stretching and they go no
stretching no I don't want to be
stretched and then you can't believe
it's already minutes in is it like my
legs I go hey into like oh yeah
no stretching okay I hate that and you
know what I also hate when they crack
your knuckles when they don't whole your
fucking fingers are the joints like you
stop stop it doesn't feel good I know
are they pull your toes and everything
yeah knock off I don't
and now you'll do it until you feel okay
okay I'm gonna realize okay call orgasm
with our activation okay yeah okay so
you feel so you see when you do when you
when you're doing is very quick to two
times you can when you squeeze is all
guessing from throw up how do you even
watch this guy that was awesome so
discussed and now you do it if you okay
I can yell again no orgasm without so
catalyst don't make me want so you feel
so you think when you do with me when
you get it exactly to two times good
please oh god oh my god
well he's oh he looks like Yoda doesn't
he
and he sound like Yoda this guy started
a left again he's like I'm watching you
come listen when you squeeze all get
them coming up I chase yeah I picture
the teeth
he does that I pick a button and you
like oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah I
squeeze my dick uh-huh Matthew tell yo
die motherfucker imagine hearing that
sound much yeah that's weird on when
you're with him though that's what
you're going to hear I know yeah Rob Rob
I guess are you doing Tom yeah rah rah
what if he just comes he though you
crazy beyond the gland penis I'm gonna
throw up yeah
what if you had to get a massage and
he's a massage therapist but then that's
the finale to it he comes
so the finale is he's like and you're
like what's going on he's like hot time
but it's like the best massage you know
yeah you just have to watch him come
[Laughter]
thank you sir yeah seriously what if no
really let's consider it what if he
gives a really good massage but then at
the end he comes like I think I'm fine
with it
it doesn't come on me right no it's not
it it's not an invisible company but he
was just doing yeah all right
if it was the best one ever you would be
in such a relaxed state that he you know
what you know what happens in that
relaxed state you you're cool with more
like in other words you're like yours
you're you're down with whatever
somebody wants to do so he's like yeah
I'm going to come you'd be like alright
well wait don't wait close your eye I
don't want to go with my eye right close
your eyes no I don't want those your
eyes oh my can close your eyes all right
right now you're such a relax listen
you're in such a relaxed state you're
you're barely on the brink like I'm
conscious
here here you're like jello he goes he
goes species and on the recession and
you go oh thank you with hot tea and you
know okay ah that's all you hear and
then he just he just can't why don't you
like that it's nice he's so creepy okay
what is it listen is okay what if he's a
chef and he makes the most awesome food
it's a personal chef and he's over at
our house and I'm making you like an
exotic seven-course meal okay but the
payment is you have to watch him come
like that and he stands there yours
anyways now you're Bill Nye you're okay
and he stands there and he gets totally
naked and you watch him do the fifty
fifty fifteen
Lingam thing yeah and then he and the
grand finale as he comes on your lap
wait why'd you have to come on your lap
just part of his thing that's payment
well the enemy and he comes on your
thighs yes
you got the dinner napkin you've got the
dinner napkin there you finish your meal
yeah at the grand finale like did you
like that meal you go yeah he goes now I
have to not payment is now and he goes
open you eyes watch me come and then he
goes 50 so it's wrong to oh my gosh yeah
and he does it 50 times and then he does
his anal glands and then he comes there
he goes enjoy him yup that's it we'll
get to watch it you have to watch every
stroke every how good is the dinner it's
so good it's like I really Michelin star
100% watch it i 100% wouldn't you yeah
that's not a lot to pay for a good meal
but you're watching that guy come and
stroke his dick for I mean that's 300
strokes it's going to be a while can I
here's what I would ask can I eat
dessert through that
I love you you feel orgasm right now
you're here I conquered is awesome
without actually like right you like so
you feel so you see when you do when
keep loading dinner get done I gotta pay
for dinner yeah when you squeeze is all
get them coming up I gotta pay for this
meal so would you do that yeah that's
not that much to pay for a really good
dinner thank you well then I don't
understand why you wouldn't let him make
love to you what it you're gonna have a
great time
no I don't like it I'm very selective of
who I let's do that to me cooking
Harry's one one rice I give you time to
write up site we've come Falls your
pizza time back with the time about a
lot a lot of run how often am i doing
this you have to do every day and who
you can control okay this you can really
fuck though I'm serious he can really
fuck he nasty though you're not fucking
nobody he's jerking his dick 300 times
ago if you were fucking on the regular
he wouldn't be doing this hog stroking
oh my god that's my new favorite song
it's so horrible
vegan vagina I don't know it's worse the
vegan vagina guy or this guy I hate them
both now a vegan vagina guys will way
worser he nasty alright we gotta go
god it's so gross I'm so disappointed
I'm so angry we closed on hand hot we're
going to screen is not hot outside in
here it's freezing my feet are I'm
standing outside we're gonna go swimming
out okay I love you we get to new she
okay let's see here we have here this is
a STIs hell um big tits fart song by
bizarre theory cool alright I like it
thanks listen in the show please go to
your mom's house podcast calm a mom top
I'm I'm home pumpkin and for Christina
go mm ranch calm okay and for mine Tom
Segura calm
thanks again okay okay and that's it
thanks guys thanks Jean Giraud to rot
very good yeah buddy
why thank you all right dad okay I'm
gonna have to require we do this show
[Music]
please don't
I can't help it and that this is Melvin
yeah it's a sewage canal I mean what the
fuck is that
well he farted in the car when we were
on the way to Country Club farting
loudly oh my god remember when they
farted in front of our nanny this
I'll have our fingerprints in the
intestines okay immediately go to the
doctor
seriously like a new brother
[Music]
am i dead breathing loudly super sweet
offers like me laughter chatter no
flying all over and down I've been on
the wavelength if you googled gee boobs
Tyler the license okay
is that true reserve procuracy wanting
it into the real test you got to get the
substance the Google European bra sizes
versus American okay the broad it's
ill-fitting and exciting and because
only out of it you want them spelling
out can you show me how you can show
them how those big kids fight they can
be serious
[Music]